well hello good people Eber here with
hard-working acts and after AMD
announced their a knobby GPU
architecture and the new arts 5700 XT
and the 5700 that is used in Nvidia team
green had the perfect opportunity to
respond in some way and that's exactly
what they're doing now instead of
cutting prices of their current art X
lineup they're actually replacing almost
the entire line up with some new GPUs so
this is the RT X super performance
review so even before Navi hits the
store shelves
it'll have to compete with what Nvidia
is calling their Super Series and yeah
it's a terrible name I really want to
know your thoughts about this super
branding in the comments but nonetheless
these new GPUs have more cores faster
clock speeds and in some cases revised
memory layout now in Vita is also
pricing these GPUs aggressively so that
could be the worst possible news for the
RX 5700 XT and the 5700 now you won't be
able to run out and pick up one of these
GPUs right away and I'll get to that
shortly first a quick word from our
sponsor also I'll be leaving timestamps
in the description down below just so
you can easily navigate through the
video well no they where'd you come from
it don't matter it's a path where I'm
going well I don't really need a new
Mouse right now sure we'll see everybody
loves a 4-way hidden d-pad and a cool
OLED display plus I'm quite sensitive at
24,000 dpi Plus RGB you got a try what
was I thinking saying no to you the MM
830 by Cooler Master the mouse you
didn't see coming
check it out below alright so let's
start with the bad news first
Nvidia is taking a page out of Andy
radians playbook by paper launching the
RT X 2070 super and the RT X 2060 super
reviews go alive today and you can place
an order for a founders edition but
actual availability at retailers and
reviews for custom cards will be on July
the 9th the RT X 2080 super will follow
later in July now if you think about it
this is a great business move by Nvidia
although I'm not really a fan of it
but at the same time it'll also allow us
the opportunity to use these super
series GPUs in our rx 5700 reviews so at
this point the Radeon team should be
worried but there's also some more good
news
this time the founders Edition won't
cost one penny more than invidious
reference prices now sure those cards
won't come pre overclocked but you can
do that yourselves anyways also every
r-tx Super Series cards will come with
two free RTX enabled games so in this
case you get control and Wolfenstein
Youngblood together they're worth about
$90 so it's a pretty good deal so what
are these super cards other than a
really weird name well let's actually
take a look at invidious lineup and what
its gonna look like
right now the r-tx 20 ATT I will stick
to $1,000 and remain at the top of
invidious stack but the r-tx 2080 and
the 2070 are being discontinued they're
being replaced by the identically priced
$700 RTX 2080 super and the $500 RTX
2070 super now the r-tx 2060 super is a
bit of a different approach since it
costs $400 but it isn't replacing the
r-tx 2060 since that card will stick to
around 350 dollars this might seem odd
but when you pop in these new cards into
this you can understand what Nvidia did
by discontinuing the r-tx 2070 they're
saving it from getting beaten by the RX
5700 XT while also introducing a higher
performing card at the same price
now the 5700 XT slots right between the
r-tx 27 super and the r-tx 2060 super I
can see the same thing for about the RX
5700 AMD's $380 card was supposed to
beat the Arctic's 2060 but now it has to
compete against the RT x 2060 super and
that's just $20 more now the 2070 super
uses the t 104 core instead of the tu
106 and it has 256 more cuda cores than
the RT x 2070 it also operates at much
higher core clocks and that should bring
its performance right near the Arctic's
2080 but power consumptions has
increased by about 40 watts also some of
the rumors were obviously wrong and
memory frequencies have stuck to being
the same
even then VRTX 2070 super should
basically give you RTX 2080 performance
for 2070 prices the 2060 super still
uses CT 106 core but it's now being
unlocked to offer almost as many cores
as the older r-tx 2070 probably the most
important change from the r-tx 2060 is
that nvidia equip this card with 8
gigabytes of gddr3 and a 256 bit
interface without that I don't think it
would have competed very well against
the rx 5,700 power hasn't even gone up
by all that much either so that's nice
so what about the cards themselves well
the ones we have are the basic founders
editions which don't look all that much
different from the original 2070 and the
2060 the heatsink and shroud bill
quality is just so much better than the
rx 5700 series but the only thing I
don't like is the mirror like area and
video added when the card is installed
into a case it can reflect everything
from LED strips to areas where you've
tucked away or cables I mean at this
point I might as well classify these
super cards as a beauty product it
really is because it has a mirror on it
guys it really does now other than that
you have the same eight plus six pin
power connector layout on the 27 t super
and we are mounted eight pin on the 2060
super I mean you guys have seen these
cars before and in my opinion for the
looks I'd rather go for a founders
edition instead of a custom card from
your partner but in this case I just
don't like the mirror finish but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
all right so if you've skip to the
performance segment I do want to mention
something very important before getting
into the benchmarks an actual review
isn't really possible without having
looked at the way how the RX 5,700 XD
and the 5700 perform compared to these
super cards so definitely stay tuned for
a lot more content around when the rx
5000 series cards finally came out let's
do a quick rundown of our test system it
features a core I 999 hundred x or
o'clock to four point nine gigahertz on
all cores and Asus X to 99 Strix eman
the board 64 gigabytes of g.skill tried
and Z clocked at thirty six hundred
megahertz NAC Sonic focus gold 850 watt
power supply it's running Windows 10
professional with all the latest updates
installed now with that out of the way
let's start with some benchmarks
this one's gonna be a little bit
different I'm actually gonna start with
some of the games that people actually
play these days including overwatch
Rainbow six siege and yes fortnight and
pop G and as you can see from these
results the r-tx 2060 super can't
actually beat the Arctic's 2070 but it
comes really close in some cases it also
stays out in front of the arctic's 2060
by between 10 and 17 percent now Nvidia
claims that they 2070 super is pretty
much an RT X 2080 for less money and
these first four games show that's
almost a case but not quite there's a
huge 15 to 20 percent improvement
against the RT X 2070 and that'll be
very important when it comes to
competing against the RX 5700 XT alright
so let's move on to some more typical
benchmark games with Assassin's Creed
Odyssey and as we run through all of
these results you'll likely see the
similarities to the last benchmarks that
means the RT x 2070 super pretty much
lines up just below or equal to the RT x
20 80 and the RT x 20 60 super almost
matches an RT x 2070 there really aren't
any exceptions to this either with the
performance scaling almost linear
between the super and non super RT X
cards but will that really be enough for
what's coming from AMD I can't say that
yet since were a little less than a week
away from that launch if Amy's published
benchmarks are any indication things
that are gonna be pretty interesting
power consumption is pretty much in line
with what we expected relative to
performance the RT X 2060 super doesn't
really require all that much more juice
than the 2060 but the RT X 2070 super
almost needs our tix 2080 power input
levels so that's something to keep in
mind so this one's gonna be a bit hard
to conclude since without the rx 5700
series in the charts there's no way of
actually knowing how good these cards
are having said that we can quickly go
over how they compare against Nvidia is
current offerings you see right now will
the RT X 2070 super is accomplished here
is bigger news because you're paying the
exact same price as the RT X 2070 but
you're getting in return an average of
15 to 20 percent better frame rates now
sure a lot of people might say that five
million dollars is still expensive and I
completely agree with you it isn't cheap
but you got to remember that the price
still remain the same now with the r-tx
2060 super I'm not really a fan of what
NVIDIA did with this thing I mean I
appreciate that the performance levels
almost matched the r-tx 2070 but do keep
in mind that they were paying an extra
$50 over the r-tx 2060 but in return
you're only getting roughly 10 to 17
percent better performance now it's
obvious that Nvidia had to introduce
this card because it's the only way that
it can outperform the rx 3700 and
nothing more so for now I think I'm
gonna leave it here since a lot of these
performance results don't mean much
until we know how they line up against
the rx 5000 series it's great to see how
aim these moves pushes Nvidia to do
something but we're just gonna have to
wait and see how this is gonna help play
out so definitely stick around for a lot
more content in the pipeline my meatball
with hydra connects thank you so much
for watching let me know what you guys
think about the new supercars from
Nvidia in the comments down below I'm
signing off and I'll see you guys in the
next one